good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight you may have seen clips
of it dr. Anthony foul she testified
before Congress say to explain how much
longer masked quarantines must last and
what other sacrifices the rest of us
need to make in order to fight the Lujan
coronavirus foul she has never been
elected to anything you'd never know it
many of our leaders believe his every
word is tantamount to law and in effect
it has been just how wise is the man
making these laws easy rooted in science
we'll let you decide in just a minute
but first tonight no matter how long
these lockdowns do go on we're starting
to see the outlines of the damage they
have caused so far
a recent working paper released by the
Becker Friedman Institute University of
Chicago concludes that out of at least
33 million American jobs that have
disappeared recently more than 40% of
them will be gone forever those jobs
will never come back even once all
government restrictions are lifted now
if that turns out to be true and of
course we hope it isn't but if it is
that would mean nearly 14 million
Americans would be languishing in long
term unemployment for perspective during
the Great Recession of 2008 whose
effects we feel even now job losses
peaked at about 10 million so this is an
unprecedented disaster for American
families what we're living through and
it's compounding what was already there
thanks to a series of ugly changes to
the American economy even before the
pandemic many people were stuck in jobs
with lower pay and fewer benefits than
the ones they lost a decade ago millions
have no savings and are suffocating
beneath mountains of student debt and
credit card debt this was already a
country with declining life expectancy
and growing inequality in the middle
class that was fading and the quarter
virus pandemic accelerated those trends
so our job now our main job before
anything else is to fix that damage
everything depends on fixing it so
that's the sad backdrop to the House of
Representatives new 1800 page
coronavirus relief bill which was
released today anything our Congress
does at the moment must first and
foremost prevent ordinary people from
slipping beneath the waves in a
statement today Speaker Nancy Pelosi
assured
that her bill this bill will do just
that we can all agree that we must open
our economy as quickly as we can but we
must do so based on science and data and
we must do so in a way that reaches all
Americans in a way that addresses the
disparities we have seen so that we can
assess the full extent of the
coronavirus and defeat it we all know
that we must put more money in the
pockets of the American people this is
not only necessary for their survival
but it is also a stimulus to the economy
direct payments unemployment insurance
rental and mortgage help and food and
student loan assistance among other
things are essential to relieve the fear
that many families are facing among
other things
speaker Pelosi just said what are those
things well the first thing to know
about this bill is that it's big maybe
the biggest piece of legislation ever
proposed in the US history the estimated
price tag for everything in this bill is
3 trillion dollars that's close to
ninety percent of the nation's entire
annual tax revenue and keep in mind that
comes close on the heels of the last
coronavirus relief bill that cost about
two trillion dollars and of course our
usual annual spending is still there it
hasn't disappeared so altogether that's
an awful lot of expenses and every
single new dollar will have to be
borrowed because there aren't any left
that means that when the smoke clears
from all this spending only China would
be able to bail us out
they'll have to they're the only ones
who can afford it China has the
strongest balance sheet in the world at
that point we will be their vassals so
is it worth it what will we get in
return for doing that well we spent all
day reading Pelosi's bill to find out
too few did that we did and here's what
we found
first and most glaringly with more than
30 million Americans out of work really
the last thing we need is more illegal
low-wage labor from abroad yet this bill
goes out of its way to supply illegal
immigrants who in case you needed to be
reminded have no right to be here in the
first place with billions in taxpayer
dollars according to House Democrats
illegal immigrants must have a right to
have the $1,200
facts that American citizens received in
the last bill they'd also received the
same direct payments as American
citizens going forward so in effect it's
a huge payoff the Democratic Party's
most cherished constituency a group
that's not even allowed to be here and
then it goes on from there the bill
contains an amnesty provision for the
duration of the coronavirus crisis
that's something I'd like to see
extended a very long time all illegal
immigrants employed in so-called
essential services would be shielded
from deportation and their employers
would be shielded to people who hire
illegal aliens could not be prosecuted
now don't be fooled this is not about
protecting physicians who are critical
to providing medical care to the rest of
us current essential workers as they are
defined in this bill is in fact an
enormous category that spans almost
every part of the American economy it
includes employees in food services
laundry waste management childcare
agriculture transportation restaurants
as well as any retail worker in America
who works at a location that sells food
or beverages this is a blanket amnesty
for virtually every illegal alien who
has already taken an American job and
once this amnesty is granted it will
never be taken away bet on that no
matter what they tell you anyone who
lives in Washington can't confirm that
once passed it's not going away and at
that point there will be no more debate
about illegal immigration the issue will
be settled permanently and Democrats
will win every presidential election for
the rest of your life the rest of your
children's lives the rest of your
grandchildren's lives that's the point
of this but the bill keeps going from
there the bill would automatically
extend current guest worker visas while
raising the ceiling for additional ones
Democrats have called this bill the
heroes Act they're telling you it will
help health care workers but as of
tonight thousands of American health
care workers are being furloughed from
their jobs or fired entirely this bill
remarkably orders DHS to expedite visa
processing for foreigners who want to
come to the US and work in health care
got that American health care workers
laid off now that could be replaced by
foreigners willing to work for less we
don't have to guess if that could happen
it's happened throughout American
industries under this bill it would help
into our health care system as well
sorry unemployed Americans better get
used to drawing a government check
that's your future and then there's the
long section in this legislation about
drugs the bill is strongly in favor of
drugs probably because when you're high
you're less likely to think or worry
about what else is in the bill the bill
mentions cannabis 68 times in orders the
federal government to produce an annual
report on quote expanding access to
financial services for minority owned
and women-owned cannabis related
legitimate businesses Democrats would
like to see more drug sales in minority
neighborhoods that's in this bill keep
in mind these are the people calling you
a racist and the bill makes it clear
they still believe you are the bill
mentions diversity at least 20 times it
would order all federal government
agencies to the greatest extent possible
to hold deposits and minority-owned
banks okay fine but what does the
pandemic in our response to it have to
do with race politics stupid question in
the Democratic Party everything has to
do with race politics all the time it's
the primary way they get and keep power
race politics is the only program they
have that and more crime and increase
censorship this bill Believe It or Not
also contains a prison break provision
it's like a Saturday live sketch this
bill would order the release of every
federal prisoner who has asthma diabetes
or is over 50 years of age unless the
Bureau of Prisons affirmatively proves
the in mating question is likely to
commit violence against a specific
person not in general against a specific
person here's the censorship part and
it's part of a growing and ominous theme
in that direction the theme will prevent
you from saying or believing what you
like this bill directs a million dollars
to the National Science Foundation to
study coronavirus quote MS
information which shouldn't be allowed
in other words shut up and stop
disagreeing with our pronouncements
that's not allowed take another hit on
your government-sponsored Abbe pen and
submit that's the message that it sends
but for the favored few the Democratic
Party's donor class the bill is far more
gentle and soothing in fact it's a
payday this bill would repeal the cap on
state and local tax deductions that
would help almost exclusively help
high-income neighborhoods in overtaxed
blue states why is that significant
because that's the beating heart of the
Democratic electorate this is a payoff
to them amazingly and you can't make
this up this bill the heroes Act would
also help a very different kind of hero
it would make lobbying shops in
Washington DC eligible for small
business loans from the federal
government in this bill lobbyists are
heroes you can't leave them out who
wrote this thing probably not scientists
lobbyists and ideologues wrote it the
same people who control the Democratic
Party the same people who badly want to
control this country